[Música]
salud con más romeros a la mar
bienvenida hablemos de la variante
omicron del cobi 19 que está acaparando
toda la información todos los titulares
y toda la preocupación y alerta mundial
que sabemos de las mutaciones de la
variante o micro en mar pues al final
detrás de toda esta alerta están
precisamente esas mutaciones entonces
vamos a dar un poco de información de
contexto a ver si ayuda a poner las
cosas en perspectiva recordemos hay
siete variantes dos de ellas se han
demostrado que son sólo de interés la
lambda y la mujer es decir son variantes
que sus mutaciones no han hecho que
prevalezcan por encima de las otras y
hay cinco que son consideradas variantes
de preocupación vamos a repasar en estas
variantes pues cuáles tienen mutaciones
cuántas y en qué se diferencian aquí ven
el número total de mutaciones que tiene
cada variante y también el número que
hay en las proteínas de espiga que son
esas como esos ganchos de los
coronavirus que sirven para penetrar en
las células para infectar las y que
también son el blanco de los anticuerpos
entonces pues si mutan mucho pueden
hacer que nos reconozcan los anticuerpos
en las vacunas en nuestro sistema inmune
entonces ahí vemos que la micrones
verdad supera con creces el resto de
mutaciones en las otras variantes y
precisamente pues ahí es por qué estamos
tan preocupados pero al final no es sólo
un tema de cuántas mutaciones hay sino
también de cuáles entonces aquí hemos
hecho un listado de las mutaciones que
se considera que son pues preocupantes y
que se sabe también a raíz de las otras
variantes que son tan pues más
transmisibles y que ayudan a que se
contagie más el virus vemos por ejemplo
que delta sólo tiene una de estas pero
es al final ha sido la que le ha hecho
ganadora al respecto de las otras
variantes y también vemos que hay dos de
ellas que se identificaron en las
variantes beta y gamma que omicron
también las tiene pero pues la mayoría
de las mutaciones de micro en raúl no se
sabe todavía cuáles son son únicas
entonces pues por ahí es que hace falta
que estemos esperando a ver qué pasa con
los estudios bueno mar y entonces me
pregunto si esta mutación es de esta
variante entonces hacen que un micrón
sea más contagiosa pues esa es la gran
pregunta como siempre una cierta
prudencia pero lo que sí sabemos y como
lo hemos repetido en los noticiarios
también es que en sudáfrica están
aumentando los contagios entonces
escuchemos y desde ahí
estábamos en un momento entre olas
después de la última ola de delta las
cosas estaban tranquilas y los casos
eran bajos ahora están en aumento a un
ritmo rápido y eso quiero dejarlo claro
los números están creciendo muy deprisa
y la infección previa solía proteger
contra delta y no parece que lo haga
contra omicron
marc seguimos hablando de omicron que no
es la única variante que se ha escrito
en sudáfrica que pasó con la primera
pues me encanta que me hagas esa
pregunta hagamos un poco de memoria
porque a veces tenemos una memoria muy
corta revolution pero lo que pasa
exactamente a finales de 2020 se detectó
la variante beta en sudafricano y una
variante que de hecho también se ha
demostrado que es más contagiosa y que
es más virulenta que en la que pues la
que es original de wuhan eso despertó
múltiples restricciones también contra
sudáfrica aunque no del mismo calado que
las actuales obviamente la variante beta
copó también los titulares de toda la
prensa en el verano del 2021 en europa
hubo varias restricciones y cuarentenas
también para que no sé también las
farmacéuticas pues se apresuraron a
decir que estaban desarrollando vacunas
nuevas pero bien al final qué pasó con
esa variante no repasemos también los
datos porque no es de lo que lo que
hemos visto y después de un poco de
tiempo es que el porcentaje de casos de
kobe atribuidos a esta variante en
áfrica sí aumentó es esa línea como la
amarilla que crece mucho pero en el
resto del mundo fue insignificante
entonces qué nos dice este gráfico pues
que la llegada de estas variantes pueden
significar que aumente por ejemplo en
sudáfrica o en el continente africano
pero no tiene por qué ser un problema de
salud pública al final beta en
septiembre de 2021 se consideró ya
indetectable y pues no prevalece en la
más gran mayoría de países
marc ante todo este panorama que estamos
hablando las farmacéuticas dicen que
pueden ahora desarrollar nuevas vacunas
en cuestión de pocos meses que tan
cierto es esto porque como también lo
dijo anteriormente dijeron quieran hacer
nuevas vacunas y no se hicieron nuevas
vacunas esta vez diferente
es una pregunta un poco tramposa por un
lado si tienen razón cuando dicen que lo
pueden hacer desarrollar en meses porque
no lo hicieron antes con la variante
beta porque no hizo falta entonces pero
les sirvió de entrenamiento y de hecho
eso es lo que explica van desde si novak
hace poco en una explicación que ahora
vamos a escuchar
desde la emergencia de la primera
variante hemos empezado preparaciones
tecnológicas para desarrollar una vacuna
contra los grupos de mutaciones cada vez
que se detecta un grupo nuevo de
mutaciones podemos empezar a desarrollar
una vacuna inmediatamente así buscamos
tener vacunas preparadas incluso cuando
no son de necesidad inmediata ahora
aceleramos los esfuerzos para
desarrollar vacunas contra omicron para
estar seguros de que estará disponible
cuando la necesitemos presidente hago
mención de omikron subiese se anda
entonces básicamente que podemos extraer
de ahí pues tanto si novak como fighter
moderna astrazéneca han usado estas
variantes que ya han surgido para
entrenarse en caso de que tengan que
modificar sus vacunas como sería pues
por ejemplo las vacunas de adn mensajero
como facer o como modernas y también en
las de en las de vectores en las de
virus víctor vectores como astrazéneca o
sputnik es muy rápido porque lo que
tienen que hacer es modificar el código
genético incluyendo las mutaciones de la
nueva variante en este caso podría ser
omicron si se necesita y eso se logra
digamos en unos días o incluso unas
pocas semanas en otras vacunas como la
del virus inactivado tarda más porque
precisamente se tiene que desactivar
este virus para que no haga daño a los
humanos cuando se inocule pero pues
también están en proceso entonces eso es
una nota de optimismo para terminar
bueno y hablamos ahora de optimismo y de
encanto usted sabe cuál es el encanto de
colombia mar por supuesto por eso llegó
aquí viendo cuatro años bueno y vamos a
ver todos los encantos que tiene este
país con nuestra segunda italia